my expertise is you know his CIA Marine
Corps 3 CI Secret Wars I had a position
in the National Security Council in 1975
as the chief of the Angola task force
running the secret war in Angola it was
a third CI secret war I was part of the
national security law creating the
National Security Council in the CI as
you know was passed in 1947 the CIA was
given this Charter to perform such other
duties and function as might be
necessary the national security
interests and given a vague authority to
protect it sorted sources and methods I
think it was in the mid 80s that I
coined this phrase the third world war
because in my research I realized that
we were not attacking the soviet union
and the CIS activities we were attacking
people in the third world and i'm going
to just quickly in the interest of time
just give you a little sense of what
that what that means this third world
war basically it's the third i believe
in terms of loss of life and human
destruction a third bloodiest war in all
of history
they undertake run operations in every
corner of the globe
they also undertook the licence of
operating just totally above and beyond
US laws they had a license if you will
to kill but also they they took that to
a license to smuggle drugs a license to
do all kinds of things to other people
in other societies and violation of
international law our law and every
principle of nations working together
for a healthier and more peaceful world
meanwhile again they battled to convert
the US legal system in such a way that
it would give them control of our
society now we have massive
documentation of what they call the
secret Wars of the CIA we don't have to
guess or speculate we had the Church
Committee investigate them in 1975 gave
us our first really in depth powerful
look inside this structure senator
Church said in the fourteen years before
he did his investigation that he found
they had run nine hundred
major operations and 3,000 minor
operations and if you extrapolate that
over the whole period of the 40 odd
years that we've had a CIA you come up
with 3,000 major operations and over
10,000 minor operations every one of
them illegal every one of them
disruptive of the lives and societies of
other people's and many of them bloody
and gory beyond comprehension almost
extensively we manipulated and organized
the overthrow of functioning
constitutional democracies in other
countries we organized secret armies and
directed them to fight and just about
every continent in the world we
encouraged ethnic minorities to rise up
and fight people like the Mosquito
Indians in Nicaragua the Kurds in the
Middle East the monks and in Southeast
Asia and of course we have organized and
we still do in funded squads and
countries around the world like the
Treasury police in El Salvador which are
responsible for most of the killing of
the 50,000 people just in the 80s and
there were 70,000 before that an
orchestration CI secret teams and
propaganda led us directly into the
Korean War we were attacking China from
the islands Quemoy Matsu thailand tibet
a lot of drug trafficking involved in
this by the way until eventually we
convinced ourselves to fight the Chinese
in Korean we had the Korean War and a
million people were killed same thing
for the Vietnam War and we have
extensive documentation of how the CIA
was involved at every level or the
national security complex because it's a
very cooperative thing into manipulating
the nation into the Vietnam War and we
wound up creating the Golden Triangle in
which the CIA air America airplanes were
flying in arms to our allies and flying
back out with heroin we launched the
largest this is something that Jimmy
Carter did Admiral Turner brags about it
the the operation in Afghanistan biggest
single operation I'm told and the
history of the CI Secret Wars and sure
enough very quickly we produce the
golden Crescent which is
the largest source of heroin perhaps in
the world today trying to summarize this
third world war that the CI the u.s.
national security complex with the
military all interwoven edit in many
different ways has been waging let me
just put it this way the best heads that
I coordinate with studying this thing we
count at least minimum figure six
million people who have been killed in
this long 40-year war that we've waged
against the people of the third world
these are not Soviets we have not been
parachuting teams into the Soviet Union
to kill and hurt and main people
especially not since 1954 when they
developed actually capability of
dropping atomic weapons on the United
States
they aren't Britain British French
Swedes Swiss Belgians we don't do bloody
gory operations in the countries of
Europe these are all people of the third
world they're people of countries like
the Congo Vietnam Kampuchea Indonesia
Nicaragua where conspicuously they nor
their governments do not have the
capability of doing any physical hurt to
the United States they don't have ICBMs
they don't have armies or navies they
could not hurt us if they wanted to
there has rarely been any evidence that
they really wanted to and that in fact
is perhaps the whole point if they had
had ICBMs we probably wouldn't have done
the things to him for fear of
retaliation cheap shots if you will
killing people of other countries of the
world who cannot defend themselves under
the guise of secrecy and under the the
rubric of national security